le cresson l'heure pour la première fois
tiana s'apprête à faire le trajet
longueuil toronto dans un véhicule loué
auprès d'un particulier j'ai fait et
je fais confiance aux autres peas ça
m'intimide pas de
participer dans ce marché neuf
l'application turow fonctionne à la
manière d'un airbnb de la location de
voitures pour les assurances avec une
couverture d'assurance similaire à celle
des locateurs de véhicules traditionnels
ne trouve pas la section détails que la
journée avait pourtant commencé avec des
difficultés techniques qui se sont
rapidement réglée elle juge que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle la fois j'ai pris
une communauté puis ça revient quand
même cher fois que je pense que wayne à
mentir c'est l'option la moins chère
sur roues est en plein essor par rapport
à l'été dernier les réservations ont
bondi de 188% à montréal
294% à toronto et de plus de 300% à
l'échelle canadienne il ya un
environnement
propice en fait la location entre
particuliers et à l'autopartage entre
particuliers
du fait de la pénurie de voitures de
location à travers le pays les
entreprises de location ayant vendu une
partie de leur voiture en début de
pandémie elle pèse maintenant à
renouveler leur parc automobile
on est très confiants sur le fait que
les gens qui vont des couvertures cet
été continuerons d'utiliser mais la
fiabilité n'est pas toujours au rendez
vous
adepte de transport actif et de
communauto joachim fels ouverture aux
pour les vacances au chalet et
économiser quelques dollars l'or s'est
fait appeler cette semaine nous
contacter pour dire que notre
réservations étaient annulées par la
personne qui nous la loi elle les
annulations exaspère de nombreux clients
les jeunes parents ont néanmoins choisi
de donner une deuxième chance à
l'application d'autopartage c'est ce à
quoi on flippe 1,25 scène souvent il
voit avec la grande fiabilité qui ont
opté comme 2 3 mais dollars pour une
location souvent haut niveau avec un
marché foisonnant avec ses 1 fiabilité
comme ça les prochaines semaines
révéleront aussi le pari est réussi
comme pour tigana qui compte utiliser
turow à l'avenir ici jean phlippe use
radio canada montréal